[Music]
[Applause]
we've reached our Max people we cannot
allow any more to come in or we will be
closed down by the ftn
Y and I'm sure you all know where the
exit signs are there's two on your left
one on your right and the front exit um
are the boys stopping from people coming
in people want to stand outside at the
front door and listen that's fine but no
more this
room all right so uh we're going to be
ready to start this
meeting will the guest speakers please
come and sit at the
day hello Mohamed Mohamed where are you
you guys have to come up here want to
come up pleas whatever four are are
represented we need you up
here this is a meeting for our community
to find out the truth and questions and
answers all right so if we're asking
that people
AC close the door
okay we will take care of it we'll take
care of it you cannot open the door let
people in I watch
[Music]
you
st if this gets too pack capacity we
cannot do any more people I'm sorry but
we are at capacity come here come
[Music]
here this is a fire safety issue these
are the regulations of the fdn
one okay so we're going to start this
meeting now
if anybody want the people were putting
out pamphlets we have them on in front
of our table if anybody's interested
they can pick them up uh there's also
membership not yet ma'am not yet not yet
and uh also at the last meeting people
were asking about membership forms we
have them up here also so would
everybody please stand and face flag
pledge alance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liy and justice for
all okay first thing on the issue here
is uh we would like to start out by
saying a big thank you to the Oasis
Christan CER for Lending us and setting
up their sound system for tonight as
most of you know nobody could hear us at
the last
[Applause]
meeting also we want everybody to know
this is basically our monthly Civic
meeting which we have every second
Wednesday of the month and which we will
be following our usual agenda this is
not what people are thinking it is this
is not a special last minute meeting um
I'd like to recognize some guests that
are in the audience today we have
Representatives councilman AO we have a
representative Congressman
McMahon uh Janelle H
Spencer uh state senator lza and we also
have a representative from the mayor's
office with us here tonight did I miss
anyone okay we also have some Civic
leaders here we have Elena Brady
president City Civic we have Dr Rich uh
Dr do Victor Dolan a m Beach resident
but he's the president of the Oldtown
Civic uh we have uh Dave be president of
the 122 Community
Council it's so crowed here am I missing
anyone raise your hand
Miss um
are we want to State how we're going to
conduct this meeting I know it's crowded
I know tensions people are full of
tensions and frenzy and everything else
about this meeting but we want to
remember civility please please make M
Beach proud just like you did at the
last
meeting this is a very tense issue I
spoke to the arch dases today they told
me they will not be sending anyone which
I thought was really unfair
because why have one group and not have
the other but they will not send anyone
so as far as our questions as far as the
parish issues and stuff like that
they're not going to be here to address
that we ask that while the guest
speakers are speaking that people you
know keep it down because we're all here
to find out
information so if you want to know
what's going on please listen everybody
and anybody that wants to ask a question
after they give their presentation will
be allowed and we're asking for 2 to 3
minutes on the limit because we can't
have this go on all night and also if
you have a question and it's already
been asked please don't ask it again ask
another
one and we're asking that people line up
in the back and one by one will approach
the
mic but first we will ask our guest
speakers to introduce themselves and
give you know an outline of who they are
what they are and what they do and we
ask that everybody have a little respect
because they're here knowing how this
community
feels so you know let's be all civil and
let's make everybody proud here
tonight okay so I'm going to hand over
the mic or they have one so they could
each introduce themselves and please
let's listen and we and anybody that
wants to ask the question has the right
to go up to the mic and ask it okay so
you got it all right good evening and
peace be upon you all my name is I am a
physical therapist I live in South Beach
father of five and I am a physical
therapist by profession currently I'm
doing my doctorate in physical therapy
in St Book
University good evening and peace upon
you all of you my name is ABD J I'm a
math teacher in a public school I have a
PhD in education and I'm the treaser of
the
organization good evening everyone
please be up on you my name is Muhammad
Saia I'm a physical therapist by
profession I have my master's degree in
Health Administration and I have my
doctor degree in physical therapy from
ston and I live in stepan Island since
98 married and have three
children okay
um I would like to get everybody u a
feedback so everybody can be in the same
page uh please bear with me I I I'm
trying we're trying to everybody to be
in the same page um the Muslim Community
in Stam island has been doubled in the
last few
years uh people moving from all over the
places uh There is five m in St Island
one of them is 3075 Richmond ter one in
Victory
Boulevard one in Target Lanes at the by
Concord High School and a small one in s
Marketplace and one in uh Park Hill
area as you can see all the five mosques
in stattin Island located on the North
Shore there is nothing on the South
Shore to serve the
community uh we've been looking for a
place in the South Shore for a long time
in the last few years uh looking around
you've been looking at places on and off
a year ago we looked at the conent we
went in and we looked at the place and
the answer we had at the time it is
under
contract and and there been I mean
exchange and we said okay then we've
been looking around so on and so forth
until April
7th we called in actually in May March
25 our real estate we were in a deal but
the deal didn't go through we called the
real estate she called the the real
estate and the conent they said it is
under contract we received a call in
April 7 that the deal didn't go through
then April 9 we signed the binder
uh May 9th we sign the contract and we
change the down
payment that was in May 9th May 12 I got
a phone call from father feny that was
my first phone call with him we never
dealt with him we never met with him
before that date that was the first
phone call from father FY or from
anybody from the church that was in May
12 and the phone call as follow muham I
don't want to sound prous but there's
people in the community have some
concern about you and your
organization we would like to talk to
you I said whatever you want we will be
happy to come and
talk he asked me for a meeting in May 15
that was on
Saturday I came with other three four
members uh father fennessy Rosemary and
uh Jasmine was in the
meeting we spoke we introduced ourselves
we introduce the purpose of the project
it will be as a daily worship Boy Scouts
Girl Scouts program after school theing
program Sports activity camping Trad
activities domestic violence and
awareness program parenting and family
counseling program directag awareness
program for youth community outreach and
enterate program counseling for student
for college
applications we explain ourself there
was issues been raised and the
conclusion of the agreement as follow
number one that they will call for an
emergency meeting on Thursday May 20 to
give the fact and the information they
hear from us to the Midland Beach
Community they will give them the fact
and they will discuss it and they
invited us they invited us to the
meeting tonight so that meeting for us
to attend that meeting since May 12th we
agreed that we be in that meeting since
May 12th and based on the agreement that
we did not attend the meeting in May
20 from that day May 20 until today the
issue was in the as everybody see was
very it start to build it toone one day
after another there was some concern
from the community and we do understand
the sensitivity of the issue we
understand the information and the fear
of the people we understand that we
realizing
but in the meantime the best way in that
type of situation is to communicate to
know one another it is unfair that
people will be labeled and nobody knows
them if I been here living in statan
Island since
1998 serving the community in statan
Island as a matter of fact one of the
groups of our Physical Therapy groups
was taking care of one of the ls in 2000
in that
conf that's who we are in 2000 one of
our groups was taking care of the nuns
in that com then we said the issue start
to a lot of question came up who's that
organization there is a link to foreign
organization where is the fund coming
from what's your relation and so on and
so forth then we been on and off with
Jasmine and I and rosemary and deby and
I really had to say something if Jasmine
follow me and I really would like to
thank them and and and and thank civic
association and I admire the relation I
mean the leadership you demonstrated a
great leadership professional respect
and I I can say but nothing but good for
the since we met in a meeting in a phone
emails we've been talking and I I admire
the the the leadership you guys have
that's what the
fact I that anything I really find they
demonstrated a great leadership they
stick with the fact they've been very
honest very open I remember Rosemary
said Muhammad listen I'm not going to be
apologetic for you but my parents
contributed to that building and I have
something in my heart and Abdul haiz
replied to her God will be praised in
that building that building is not going
anywhere God will be praised in that
building now here is a question there is
a lot of we understand there is a lot of
issues a lot of concern a lot of
questions need to be answered that's why
we here
today uh we come on here based on one
fact mutual respect and the betterment
of the community we are part of the
community we are part of statan Island
and as long as we communicate as long as
we know each other I think we can
overcome any challenges I would like I
to address those issues one after
another and definitely I I will not go
out of that Hall until everybody has a
choice to voice his concern and we'll
answer it thank you very much